Hello Freak bitches.
I Dunno,
but I feel like,
remember when you told me that story about the monkey that you had,
that you had when you were on fear factor.
Beat my ass.
That when you held that little thing you thought this thing's made a word that
that's what I feel when I get you up on my shoulder.
I'm like,
damn,
this thing's made of wood.
Absolutely.
Start beep do.
I was telling Jamie,
I've,
I think I've told you this story,
I've probably told to everybody I've met that I have a little baby champ on the
set of Newsradio like way back in the day it was supposed to be in some stuff
that I tell you this,
I probably said it before.
This little motherfucker was on my back and he hit me a couple of times and I
was stunned.
I was like,
oh no,
this is not what I thought.
It was like.
I thought it was like a little person like,
oh,
this little person thinks he's a bad ass.
Let me just calm him down.
Now he got on top of HR,
just hit me a couple times.
On the back and I was like,
what in the fuck?
I just was thinking it immediately.
I started doing the math in my head and thinking what it would be like to be
confronted by a full grown chimp.
Okay,
well that's my argument with the silver back versus grizzly.
You said Grizzly because grizzlies or even more and more of the fucking bad ass
than a chimp.
Grizzly.
Grizzly can't like,
there's no way a chimp can outrun a grizzly.
There's no way.
Not a chance in hell.
What's this?
I don't know if that's true.
What is a silver back?
Full speed.
I seen one of those things.
No grizzly can outrun a soda.
I know it.
I'm strong.
I feel confident.
I think chimps are faster than gorillas and I think at grizzly can outrun a
chimp.
And I sat for me,
I think there's no way the guerrillas getting fucked.
He's getting D's,
dude.
I'm telling you right now,
big ass and tiering your hands feel like when they shake mine.
So I would be,
I guess I'm not like a grizzly,
but a giant dude
would crumple you like half empty pop.
It wouldn't even,
it would even be like,
you wouldn't even feel you.
He would go through you like whipped cream fee.
25 miles an hour.
Top speed.
Why does it say feels like 25 feels late in 25 similar animals speeds 34 but it
feels like 25 I don't understand.
What that means is from someone riding it's back.
Get to a different website says,
is that really what this is?
Oh my God,
I love the name.
What PD?
Where'd that come from?
Do you know where that came from?
For elk speed of animals.com
a walk.
PD?
Yeah.
What does it,
where does that word come?
That's what an elk is.
Dude,
I but I why?
It's actually a whopping [inaudible] who called it the [inaudible].
What does that,
where does that name come from?
I've heard it.
It's a cool name.
Wapa Wednesday is the Hashtag.
Cam uses it a lot.
Powerful.
Wapa he Wednesday
champ.
I said a silver back.
I don't want to know is what you think a champ is faster.
Jump off there.
Don't you think in chip is faster than a gorilla?
[inaudible] silver back.
Okay.
Have you seen a silver back come out of the fricking
told you so?
Yes.
What I'm thinking
it's just like an archery argument.
Yeah.
Maybe.
I think the bear gets a heavy arrow,
slower speed,
fast Arrow,
but there's not much of a difference in the speed.
It's real close and a grizzly bear is so much bigger.
Moving so much more mass around like have a big grizzly is 500 pounds a silver
back.
I'm pretty sure.
I mean a big grizzly interior,
grizzly,
what does a big one,
like 900 is that really not?
I'm not a mountain grizzly.
When you look it up,
the more aggressive ones just say six or 700 and the really big ones,
the coastal ones,
right,
which they call brown bears,
first rounders.
Why do they call them that?
But because it's the same animal,
different specie,
is it?
Yes.
Yeah.
They're don't interbreed or anything bigger.
The break,
there's just totally different bear.
Yeah.
One looks like a Volkswagen with hair and one looks more like a Ford truck.
It's one of those other things where the the one that has the scary,
your name is like not the biggest one,
which is weird.
Like Brown bear sounded like,
oh he's so cuddly.
And Yeah,
those buses reac island,
they sell coke Klondike bars.
That's right.
What would you do for a Klondike Bar?
I fucking power because your buddy,
I'm your buddy.
I live in a place where there's no vegetables.
It's a conspiracy theory.
Told her bears brought that up.
They literally made those to make themselves look cuddly.
So humans would be stupid enough to walk up to him.
Do you think it's like a nature trick?
Like nature made them cool to look at.
So we don't mind as much that they're murderers.
I would argue Disney fucking Disney,
right?
Like that Bambi movie so slower by 10 miles an hour.
The,
is there anyone that has the doctor told you no.
But is there any strength of a silver back versus a grizzly?
And I say this saying,
I really respect grizzly bears and brown bears cause you know that well the
concerns of a lot of grizzly bears and brown bears that were listening to them
and they were there,
they're pumped.
I think that um,
they're all dangerous and ferocious and I'm thinking silver back versus the
nigger is you think you would win?
Yeah.
Maybe people will listen to this podcast and he's put it in the Po in the posts.
What we need to know what people want to know.
I wouldn't want to fight a 38 pound rat.
No.
Be fucking terrified to fight at 38 pound rat.
So the idea of 38 I just cannot put a number cause that's a fucking giant rat
man.
Yeah,
but he should have said 30 40.
I know,
but like 48
what's a house cat weigh like 10 pounds.
No Way.
That's the Garfield waste.
10.
Okay.
Like seven,
seven pounds.
I'm like that.
I would think something along those lines.
Okay.
Now,
now make it bigger.
Like keep it like a what?
What size is it becomes unmanageable.
First off,
let's,
if you're not wearing welding gloves,
a 10 pound in shape house cat,
you're not talking like Garfield,
you're talking like,
I dunno,
let's talk about a Conor Mcgregor Garfield at coming in at 10,
like a real good tiger cat.
Like one of them,
you know those,
those ones like real common house cat ones to look like a little picture.
This pic,
if you grabbed a 10 pound mountain lion,
do you think you can control that thing?
There's no way.
My neighbor,
my neighbor,
a 38 pound,
my neighbors,
good buddy of mine and he,
uh,
he saw a mountain lion and he saw a mountain lion when they was walking his dog.
It's got these little cutie dogs.
He's walking this little cutie dogs and he saw this fucking thing,
so its tail and picked it up,
picked the dogs up and ran back to his house.
And uh,
then mark got a website,
got on a website and found out that,
uh,
that they attract this animal and that it a,
it had a collar on it and uh,
the tracked it and it got hit by a car.
On the five and he's explaining like how the whole,
the whole thing went down and I was like,
Whoa,
like that thing you were walking your dogs and this big ass cat,
it's was like 120 pound plus cat.
So the actual cat that had a collar,
he knew that's the one he encountered.
Yeah.
He saw,
he saw the collar and then he went on the website and you can track because he,
he'd found out that this cat had died and when he found out the cat died,
he went and uh oh the sound of whiskey.
Are you good?
Yeah,
I'm good dude.
Trust me,
you're Yeti's talking a lot of stupid shit.
I never even touch that.
I definitely have.
How dare you.
Are you one of those guys bro?
We've been drunk cause me Bro,
quit bullying me.
Sorry.
That's my instinct.
What we were just,
what,
what the fuck was I just getting it to it?
I had on the rat.
Oh yeah.
Among other things.
So a silver back is essentially like a super,
a super prime it right.
The most super,
super prime.
Yes.
But a bear is one of the most super,
Super Freak Predator animal freak out.
Things like if a bear was little,
like a nine pound bear,
like the size of a nine pound rat was trying to kill you,
you'd would be freaking the fuck out if it was running annual,
like a little tiny bear,
you'd be fucking terrified.
Now think of a giant one and realize how PR you.
You are totally defenseless and I don't think it's going to be that much
difference for literally think of a silver back gorilla with the way they're
built and they swing around.
I think if he stood on the chest of a grizzly can grab its paws and literally
rip its arms out and beat it with it.
Wow.
That's King Kong was a good movie.
I agree with you there.
I enjoyed it as much as the next name,
I think in a Kong,
but I believe that.
I don't think that's correct.
I don't think they're that strong.
The thumb,
the thumb doves does give an advantage of,
right.
It could grab,
wait,
it's a little smarter.
Yes,
Jamie Gray,
but he just,
the bears way stronger,
way stronger,
way stronger.
It could smack at once in a while.
I've seen that.
I've seen or I've seen a grown mountain grizzly hit a moose and Canada.
Yeah,
you told me that,
that I've seen you saw it with your own eyes.
Right.
Is there any solid information of strength of a silver back for,
there's not,
there's just a lot of people that have argued this on the Internet for the last
five to 10 we get dangerously close to this argument.
Seriously.
Why don't they put Thor's hammer on the ground have and like put a,
put a Taco in it or something to where a grizzly has to try to grab it and pull
it off and have a sensor versus the silver back down.
Well,
the grizzly definitely can't grab as hard cause it doesn't have thumbs like we
talked about,
but I think,
yeah,
but that's relative to a beating,
right?
Who,
how many fighters have a big ass and a lot of like leg power,
cro cough versus someone that's just sheer grill up top.
Let's do go there.
I just wonder how strong a gorilla really is in comparison to which essentially
like a giant dog.
I just think he's going to get far you crazy.
You think silver back is equivalent to a giant dog bear is what I'm saying is a
bear.
A bear is like essentially like a giant house,
but why would I call it silver back put dog.